position de loi pour 10 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois qui va nous
rejoindre madame la rapporteur cher
Françoise chers collègues je me réjouis
de l'examen aujourd'hui d'une
proposition de loi corps rédigée avec
mes collègues de la délégation au droit
des femmes Dominique Verrien et Martine
filleul cette proposition de loi
issue des travaux de notre délégation
consacrée à la parité dans la haute
fonction publique et au bilan
d'application des 10 ans de la loi dites
sauvadais du 12 mars 20 12 pardon elle
fait suite au rapport que mes collègues
ont publié en juin 2022 intitulé parité
dans la haute fonction publique changer
de braquet 10 ans après la loi sauvadais
la loi Sauvadet impose aux employeurs
publics de respecter une proportion
minimale de chaque sexe pour les primo
nominations dans près de 6000 emplois
d'encadrement supérieur et de direction
depuis 2017 ce quota est 40% et à ta
sortie de pénalité financière s'élevant
à 90 000 euros par unité manquante
progressivement ces obligations
paritaires ont été atteintes dans les
trois fonctions publiques ainsi le taux
de primonomination féminine dans les
emplois d'encadrement supérieur et de
direction à progresser de 10 points
entre 2013 et 2020 en 2020 le quota a
même été atteint pour la première fois
simultanément dans les trois versants de
la fonction publique nous avons
toutefois identifié trois principaux
points de vigilance premièrement
déclinez par fonction publique et par
ministère les résultats sont instables
d'une année sur l'autre avec une
progression en dents de scie
deuxièmement les quotas sauvadec sont
des quotas de flux n'ont pas conduit à
une accélération notable du stock
c'est-à-dire de la proportion de femmes
dans les emplois de direction et
d'encadrement les femmes n'occupent
aujourd'hui encore qu'un tiers des
emplois d'encadrement supérieurs et
dirigeants de la fonction publique
pourtant l'objectif final des quotas
sauvadais et précisément d'agir sur le
stock au-delà du flux troisièmement la
proportion de femmes reste plus faible
dans les ministères historiquesment
masculins et dans les emplois considérés
comme plus prestigieux ou plus technique
au sein de la fonction publique d'État
la proportion de femmes
occupant un emploi supérieur était de
33% en 2020 au niveau global avec des
variations notables entre ministère
46% pour le ministère des affaires
sociales 32% pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur 31 pour celui de la culture
et 27% pour celui de l'économie et des
finances cependant dans la fonction
publique d'État la proportion de femmes
augmente au sein de tous les postes y
compris à plus haut niveau de
responsabilité
au sein de la fonction publique
territoriale la proportion de femmes
nommées à des postes à responsabilités à
nettement augmenter mais les nominations
ont concernées essentiellement des
postes de directeur adjoint des services
des géants
occupés à 41% par des femmes en 2020
tandis que seuls de Directeur Général
des Services DGS et 15% des postes de
directeur général des services
techniques sont occupés par des femmes
enfin dans la fonction publique
hospitalière une féminisation
historiquement élevée cache une
situation contrastée
en 2020 42% des emplois d'encadrement
supérieur et dirigeants ils sont occupés
par des femmes pour autant les femmes
sont davantage à la tête d'établissement
sanitaire sociaux et médico-sociaux 53%
des femmes et de direction de soins 74%
de femmes dans les hôpitaux et CHU poste
considérés comme plus prestigieux la
proportion de femmes à la tête
d’établissement et respectivement de 27
et 39%. par effet de miroir les
disparités dans les postes se retrouvent
également au niveau des salaires
fortes de ces constats notre délégation
avait formulé 12 recommandations visant
à renforcer l'accès des femmes aux
responsabilités dans la haute fonction
publique
elle recommandait notamment d'élargir
les obligations paritaires et de
renforcer la mobilisation des employeurs
publics autour d'une politique d'égalité
professionnelle et salariale ambitieuse
ces recommandations ont abouties à la
rédaction de cette proposition de loi je
tiens à remercier la rapporteur
Françoise Dumont qui a été à l'écoute
des préoccupations de notre délégation
et avec qui nous avons pu collaborer
afin d'améliorer encore ce texte je
remercie également le ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique Stanislas Guérini qui s'est
montré très attentif et s'engagé à
avancer sur certaines de nos
recommandations d'ordre réglementaires
je pense notamment à des sujets
techniques mais essentiels telles que la
transparence des données celle-ci sont
aujourd'hui publiées avec un décalage de
deux ans ce qui n'est évidemment pas
satisfaisant
c'est un véritable travail de
co-construction législatives auxquelles
nous nous sommes attelés ensemble la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui présente trois grandes
avancées par rapport à la législation
actuelle tout d'abord elle renforce
l'existence l'exigence pardon des quotas
de flux en les rehaussant de 40 à
45%. ensuite elle introduit un quota de
stock à compter de 2029 un taux minimal
de 40% de personnes de chaque sexe
s'appliquera dans les emplois supérieurs
et de direction de la fonction publique
enfin elle a store la publication
d'indicateurs relatif aux écarts de
rémunération et de représentation dans
les emplois supérieurs et de direction
entre femmes et hommes
de l'égalité professionnelle a prouvé
son intérêt dans le secteur privé et je
me félicite que les employeurs publics
puissent être également astreint à la
publication de telles statistiques genre
nous ne pouvons convaincre de la
nécessité de faire progresser la parité
que si nous disposons de statistiques
objectifs vend les inégalités qui
persistent entre femmes et hommes comme
nous le répétons souvent au sein de
notre délégation il faut compter les
femmes pour que les femmes comptent si
les quotas font souvent des bas lors de
leur instauration ils font toujours
preuve de leur efficacité nous en sommes
convaincus au sein de cette délégation
tout comme nous sommes persuadés de la
nécessaire exemplarité des employeurs
publics en matière de parité
les employeurs publics emploient
aujourd'hui près de 6 millions d'agents
soit 20% de l'emploi en France et 62%
des femmes parmi ces agents toutes
catégories confondues ils peuvent et
doivent donc jouer un rôle moteur dans
la progression de l'égalité et de la
parité dans notre pays les qualités ne
progressent que sous la contrainte je
pourrais même dire hélas depuis le 8
juillet 1999 différents lois se sont
succédés pour favoriser l'accès des
femmes aux responsabilités politiques
professionnelles sociales ce texte
marque donc une nouvelle étape pour plus
de mixité dans la haute fonction
publique c'est un signal fort
d'exemplarité pour l'ensemble de notre
société une nouvelle étape qui en
appellera forcément d'autres sur la
longue route escarpée vers l'égalité une
société plus égalitaire pour l'intérêt
de tous les hommes et les femmes je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à Madame Françoise